How does taking vitamin C, when you have Lyme disease, is that a no-no?
What does it do?
So, if you have Lyme disease, is taking vitamin C a bad thing?
Well, it depends.
So, if you have a acute case of Lyme, so I categorize Lyme disease.
If you want in depth of what I'm going to share, you can go to the three phases of Lyme course right here.
But I categorize Lyme disease in three phases, that's the name of the course,
the name of the book that I wrote about Lyme disease.
So, phase one, Lyme is acute Lyme, so you just got bit by a tick.
If you have Borrelia, bacteria, or co-infections circulating in your bloodstream,
doing something to stimulate your immune system, is the right thing to do.
So, in that case, we know you should take vitamin C.
You should probably get it on an antibiotic right away.
If you have acute phase one of Lyme, if you don't treat it,
and the bacteria and or co-infections, then get inside of a cell.
So, they go through the cell membrane, they pass through a cell membrane,
and they get inside the cell.
Now, you have chronic, what has been known as chronic Lyme.
I call that phase two Lyme.
So, it's inside the cell, you know, immune stimulants will help when it's outside the cell,
and the immune stimulants and or antibiotics will not help.
If the bacteria and or viral or other bacterial co-infections go intracellular within the cell,
antibiotic don't go into cell.
Your immune system is not going to break through your cell membranes and attack the bacteria
in the cytoplasm or the cell.
You're, you know, pickled on when you're in product line,
and it becomes more difficult to treat.
And this is where people go on long-term antibiotics,
because every time it goes outside the cell to reproduce more, then you can kill it.
But it just damages your gut, damages a lot of other things,
but some people have been helped by that.
People are on immune stimulants, you know, heavy immune stimulants.
Well, that could have negative effects too, because you could move into what's called phase three,
or what I call autoimmune line.
So any time you now developed antibodies to self tissue,
wherever that line was found to be intracellular,
your immune system continues to try to kill it,
starts to create antibodies against that tissue.
And once you have antibodies against self tissue,
you're in an autoimmune state.
If you're going to be using, you know, immune stimulants like vitamin C,
you can actually make yourself worse.
So it is inherently a little bit more difficult to treat somebody with,
with autoimmune disease, and obviously,
so to say, you know, the entire course about that.
But you, it's even more difficult to treat somebody with an autoimmune disease
when they have cancer.
What I do think that cancer has an autoimmune component to it,
and a lot of people.
So,
it's, it's a balancing act of try to get your immune system to kill the cancer with,
while you're not stimulating your immune system to kill self tissue at the same time.
That's why I am, I'm not this humongous fan of intravenous vitamin C,
even for cancer patients.
And I haven't recommended it for a lot of you,
but a lot of you are doing it because you just feel glad to do it,
but you know, you have to really weigh whether it's helping you or not.
Can be about saying it's not, but if you have an autoimmune component going on as well,
then it can be a source of increased inflammation, systemic inflammation,
and tissue destruction to the tissue that you have antibodies against.
Well, that's all very complicated.
Well, that's why I have an entire course about it.
So, that's why I started off this conversation by saying,
if you're going to look at some of these courses,
you guys all know all the stuff about stuff by the cancer.
Now, start digging it into the autoimmune component,
and that might be an answer.
Some people are stuck.